i got this uh horrible message from jeff
the drunk
which was shocking
listen to this message i got from jeff
it's so great he's such a whiny little
[__] what the [__] man i never get any
[__] have time like howard my wi-fi
died i have no money coming in
for social security you know he started
to get people you know doing cameos you
know and he was making money and i think
his social security got cancelled and
then when we went on vacation people
forgot about him in his cameos
so
really affected his business
[Laughter]
business
i really should be done with you jeff
why
because you're very rude to me it's not
the howard and jeff show it's the howard
stern show no
you're moving to me right now pick it
up i do pick up on you on occasion most
times you have nothing to say you know
that well chris told me to call it
yesterday
and they said how are you going to do
the fact about the viruses
i'm really trying to understand
put your teeth in freak you i don't have
to all right what do you want henry can
i tell you about high pitch sure i heard
that
is not
allowed
on the set of blue bloods because he's
not backed
i checked with donny wahlberg eric is
allowed on the set of blue bloods
he has not shown up on the set of blue
bloods in a very long time donnie
doesn't know why but eric is not banned
you don't believe no no i don't i gave
you the facts i gave you the science and
you don't believe me what's with the
hyper stuff that's the other thing i
will ask you hates him i know it's the
jealousy you want
to fit me against hybrid no you do it
you're always complaining about chris
i called you are you are you not
vaccinated the first thing you said is i
i am not like that idiot high pitch and
then you went into the high pitch
accusation
you [__] put them up the air
all the time
unlike like a regular person you don't
give me it you don't give me your job
here's the jealousy coming right through
eric gets all the air time and jeff
doesn't get any how about eric might be
more talented than you no
thank you
but at least admit you're jealous of
high-pitched eric i mean listen to the
whole time i'm talking to you eric gets
cameo eric eric eric eric
what do you care what eric does live
your own life jeff that's the best
advice i can give you i hear to rebut is
high-pitched eric who is upset with jeff
the drunk
i get it i get why eric's upset go ahead
eric
by the way eric yeah
am i right uh
oh jeff hung up he hung up he couldn't
oh he ran
he ran ran away
because he's scared he's a baby i don't
call you every day like he does
right
you're vaccinated right i'm i'm
fascinated i'm always asking you there
you go so all of that was a lie
uh jefferson
even collecting rumors on eric you know
he's
totally obsessed
here's the final uh email about jeff's
appearance yesterday more jeff the drunk
please signed nobody
[Laughter]
listen i still love you don't worry
about it that's all that matters
blah blah blah
eric's pissed at you but don't hang up
on him i mean hang in there hold on a
second what's up eric i'm thinking
why do you get off my [__] dick
because i don't have anything against
you all you do is you have something
against me
because you're a freaking
circular [__]
and you're
it really is
so stand in my [__] life [__] you
[Music]
[__] you
[__] you trap
[Music]
[__] you jeff
this is some argument
[__] you jeff you fat [__]
shut my dick birthday
all right okay guys uh jeff hang in
there and uh eric hang in there okay all
right have a good weekend yeah you guys
we love you both we don't want you
fighting yeah there's no need to fight
all right jeff later